Josh good morning thanks for joining us
when did you start playing fortnight
night in November like early November
about one of my best friends kind of got
me on to the game and then you know then
yes overripe ever since have you missed
a day of playing fortnight here and
there not consistently how important is
fortnight to you oh very funny you would
talk about the amount of time because I
was actually up yesterday playing twitch
on one fortnight broadcasted on torch
until like 5:00 in the morning and I was
yeah I love I'm regretting I've probably
got like I think I might as well call it
but looking at sure I am regretting
there right now do you have a girlfriend
visiting visiting me right now and she
like FaceTime me at at five o'clock in
the morning and just gave me and look
like what is the longest you know that's
a fortnight for how many hours I would
say probably about like and 10 hours
probably there was one time mom Larry
mast came up came over here before we
played at the Cavaliers and they were
like a Saturday thing one and we
literally had four four TV set up in my
living room we all had our own ps4 and
we ran like a host for tonight's squad
for like 10 hours a day how many players
in the NBA play fortnight was a good
amount honestly I know Andre Drummond
plays Terrence Ross plays ping Reggie
Jackson Alec Larry now is going to
Hayward so it's going to be a decent
amount of people planned for tonight
do you know who ninja is
okay all right see the Michael Jordan of
fortnight oh I think he's the most
popular I think there is someone I'm
supposed to be so-called better
I forgot what his name is but but not
into the most popular one how about dr.
disrespect if you could meet these
unlike how important would it be to like
you're giddy you're like a little girl
who's meeting a boy band here if I said
you could meet ninja how excited would
you be okay if you could spend time with
your girlfriend or ninja explain to the
audience but what is the allure the
attraction of fortnight I think it's
just that feeling of when you win I
think that's the biggest thing because
once you get that first one because at
first you're gonna once you start
playing and I gonna understand that
you're gonna get your butt whooped and
then once you get that first win you're
like like wow like you know this is you
verse 19 you get a win you get to win
and you're like the last one standing
you like you know what like I'm the man
and they just like I got a head I got
this really good that drives at all but
you're playing you got a broken hand
right yeah does that hurt you when
playing this Oh at first it did so so
when it when it happened happened the
end of my brother had a February and
when I was in Miami so at first it was
it was okay like it would hurt my hand a
little bit have any to hold the
controller um and I had a brace on and I
took the brace off cause like you know
what I'm having a surgery
about two days anyway so I can't hurt it
any worse mmm so I took the brace off
and play it a little bit and then the
the first couple of days after the
surgery I wasn't able to play and then I
was but between the pain and actually
the actual pain and not being to play
for a night like that like that like
three or four days it was just it was a
pain in the butt okay you won a national
title at Villanova compare the feeling
of winning a national title to the first
time on fortnight because we wanted we
won the Masters have been dramatic
fashion so I got to get that the nod um
first time I won four night like I was
screaming I jumped about my chair I was
I was high I think the first time I
wanna have like one kill and everything
was the last one so they really earned
the win like you know like I kind of
earned it an over yeah I'll probably say
a little bit better but if you let's say
Villanova won by 15 in the national
title game
you guys had a pretty good cushion you
know when it's like one like 1v1 at the
end of the game like there's not much
cushioning and you get that that wind
that you should get that feeling like
you know what I'm on top of the world
right now talking to Josh Hart the
Lakers guard who certainly loves his
fortnight I love those Nike shoes that
they made did you help design the
fortnight Nike basketball shoes was
awesome and I'm an IT guy so sometimes I
wear the new Kobe's and Amitabh Kobe's
so whatever really happy they didn't
make them I have I had one of my my
friend Chris pseudonymous he actually
you know he's a kook ustym eyes and he
customized for me and we were just kind
of sitting around and we realized like
he never did that you know no one ever
did a foreign
basketballs like Carnegie towns there's
a lot of like customs again a Rick and
Morty you know Jason on Halloween and
that kind of thing and I was like no one
has ever done this it's like I love it
so I'm like you know what I'm gonna make
a splash I'm gonna be the first I'm
gonna be the first one to bring out the
four-night customs so let me do that and
it was really cool yeah it looks great
when's the last time you ran into Kobe
Bryant never you've never met him yeah
maybe maybe see if he plays for tonight
he pushed it yeah maybe that was
actually funny because I was last night
I was playing with a couple a couple
other big streamers um one named Dakotas
and the other one was named um hi
distortion and one of them actually said
that there's like you know what Josh
number would break the internet if we
had Kobe planned for tonight so I think
I'm gonna have to uh you know try to put
the word in and see if I can uh get that
going
how are my Lakers doing by the way okay
I think we were obviously doing a little
bit better but we're young we're getting
better you know and I think that's the
biggest part have you gotten yelled at
like coach Walton he wants to win so you
see maybe a couple of times we'll be
winning then I'll make like a stupid
pass or something like though I remember
I forgot working was but we're winning
you made it I made like a really stupid
like Boeing had past turnover and he
started he was snapping at me and then I
think I had like two or three back
buckets back to back to back and went
into a timeout he did look at me and
everybody started laughing passionate
sigh I love it
hey Josh it's good to have you on to
talk about something other than
basketball good luck with
return from your broken hand and good
luck more importantly with fortnight
that's Josh Hart Lakers car how good was
that but you could just hear it in his
voice
giddy for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]